I wrote it I sent it
[Music]
my ex-boyfriend and I the break of the
tail probably took longer than the
actual relationship lasted at one point
he was like I need a little bit of space
and I was like you got it and instead of
doing that I immediately sent him the
most heinous email that I have ever
written in my entire life I chose to
write it while it was raining so that I
could look outside at the rain while I
cried a few highlights from that email
if I ever made you feel like you were
less than the most important thing in my
line in a month when we meet up in Union
Square I hope you will hold me in your
arms and we can go back to being what we
were meant to be you were not and that
you said you would die for me I don't
want you to do that I just want you to
love me why and I ended it with a quote
from a Garth Brooks song even though
neither of us listened to Garth Brooks
music I went but it was this really long
super intense email he responded to it
like three or four days later and
literally just said thank you that bitch
just said thank you that's it thank you
double kiss it was the most embarrassing
thing that I have ever done the only
good thing that came out of that is when
he sent me back the email that said
thank you I was immediately over that
little turn pro tip if he asked for
space maybe don't be crazy
you